nicolas hulot bonsoir renfort alors
françois bayrou à la tribune qui prend
des engagements pour le pacte écologique
mais qui sur son site internet ne pas là
on parle à aucun moment de nature
d'environnement ni d'écologie ça veut
dire quoi que les promesses n'engagent
que ceux qui y croient et aura coûté moi
j'ai choisi plutôt que la défiance la
confiance je pense que c'est bien aussi
de temps en temps quand il ya un
événement comme ce matin quand il ya des
engagements aussi fort des uns et des
autres plutôt que deux joues de toujours
être dans la suspicion de prendre acte
franchement ce matin c'est quand même un
moment étonnant et ça concrétise quelque
part les objectifs du pacte écologique
était de demander à la communauté
politique de se mettre d'accord sur la
gravité des enjeux et la nécessité
d'engager une mutation écologique en
profondeur c'est pas un aboutissement ce
matin mais je pense que c'est un bon
point de départ
on a enfin un socle pour commencer à
travailler alors moi à ce stade là je
vais pas commencer à leur faire des
procès d'intention
d'autant que j'ai du mal à imaginer que
sur un enjeu aussi universel
fondamentale qui met en péril l'avenir
de l'humanité on puisse s'affranchir
chemin faisant d'engagement qui ont été
faits ce matin pas face à moi mais
devant les français alors ces dix
candidats ont signé donc impact on
imagine qu'ils vont appliquer les
conditions de ce pacte et pourtant
nicolas sarkozy s'est montré très
dubitatif sur le rôle d'un vice premier
ministre alors il a préféré lui un
ministre d'état qui a autorité sur un
certain nombre de ministères et de
ministre de tutelle
c'est ce sont deux approches différentes
pour opérer une cohérence de l'action
publique mais très sincèrement au moins
ayant en commun que le numéro deux du
gouvernement sera chargé du
développement durable de la prospective
de l'anticipation
c'est quand même dans l'architecturé
gouvernementale une petite révolution et
je pense qu'on fera dix fois mieux dans
ces structures quel que soit le schéma
proposé à gauche et à droite que l'on a
fait jusqu'ici vous pourriez être ce
ministre d'état ou ce vice premier
ministre et que je pense qu'à ce rôle là
qui veulent un rôle nouveau délicat
parce qu'il va falloir arbitrer
coordonnées des choix avec parfois des
logiques contradictoires
il faudra quelqu'un qui a une solide
expérience institutionnels
que preuve du contraire c'est pas mon
cas qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
proposition de l'engagement de ségolène
royal de réduire de 85 à 50% la part du
nucléaire dans l'énergie en france dans
l'utilisation énergétique on sait bien
que le débat sans a priori sans préjugés
sur les choix énergétiques de la france
s'établissait réalise une baisse aussi
brutalement à l'échelle de 15 ans faut
demander aux spécialistes
mon sentiment personnel c'est que c'est
bien que la france à moyen terme se dote
d'un véritable bouquet énergétique mais
que simultanément on baisse notre
consommation énergétique et après on
pourra valider des choix un choix plutôt
que d'autres médias deux urgences
sobriété et efficacité énergétique et à
vrai bouquet énergétique donc
progressivement baisser la part du
nucléaire au fur et à mesure que les
énergies alternatives et renouvelables
prennent le relais vous vous donnez
combien de temps pour vérifier que les
promesses faites par les candidats
seront d'abord pendant la campagne
j'espère que le débat la réflexion la
mobilisation va continuer parce que les
trois mois sont importants il faut
continuer à maintenir cette de vigilance
cette exigence je rappelle que tous les
jours il ya dix mille personnes
supplémentaires qui viennent signer le
pacte écologique puis après au lendemain
du second tour on aurait vite fixé si
vous voyant deux fois les deux tours
vous donner des consignes non non non
donner des consignes il n'en est pas
question
reprendre la parole si par exemple
effectivement un candidat oublié chemin
faisant des engagements pourquoi pas
mais honnêtement je suis pas dans cet
état d'esprit pour l'instant j'ai repris
ma neutralité je suis resté dans mon
engagement associatif et j'ai pas à me
substituer aux consciences des uns des
autres
merci nicolas hulot